hey this is a funny one FoxNews had a
sort of town hall with or an audience of
law enforcement and first responders and
it went horribly wrong when not a single
one of them maybe one person in the
audience was willing to validate the
entire war on cops narrative that Fox
News has been pushing for years this is
hilarious and when it happens it
actually happened during the Bernie
Sanders town hall on Fox News a few
months ago I'll tell you about that in a
second if you've forgotten about it but
first let's take a look at a clip where
Fox News tries to expose the violent
evil anti-police leftists by saying put
your hands up if you've had liquids
thrown at you or been heckled or
disrespected or whatever and maybe one
hand goes up it might have been someone
just trying to say they needed to get up
to go to the bathroom truly truly
awkward take a look at this you know the
conversation in this country has really
changed you have lawmakers that are
going to restaurants they're harassed
with their families and they have to
think okay wife/husband how do we
prepare for this if we get into this
situation you have firefighters you have
police officers on the street they have
to think what do we do when this happens
how did we get to that place don't look
at that look at that post New York Post
says how dare you calling these men and
these women that are doing this throwing
water throwing no matter how high when
President Trump stands up and says I'm
for the taxpayers and the citizens and
the people who came here legally right
it resonates so much with people because
you see another side of the aisle an
entire party saying we're the party of
illegality we're the party of non
citizenship and he says now once last
time I checked America still matters all
right can we see the hands of the people
here today the first responders in law
enforcement who have encountered
anything like that in the last year or
so in New York or wherever you are it
with water hit with milk disrespected
taunted all right now anyone that has
well that's good all right well let's
talk let's talk a little bit about just
generally who would like to talk on TV
right now I would imagine everybody
another swing and a Miss again there was
one guy sort of in the back row who kind
of seemed like he was raising a finger I
don't know if he was just getting a fly
away from him but again
the narrative failing and this is one of
those tired old narratives that the
right-wing media tries to push in
reaction to stories about police killing
unarmed black teens and black men the
real war is against police and the real
problem they want us to believe is that
the left hates public servants and law
enforcement
the truth is let's just step aside from
the partisanship we have a country of
three hundred and forty million people
we can find anecdotal examples of
everything you can at the same time have
examples of police behaving badly
who should be held to account for it but
mostly police departments made up of
good people trying to do the right thing
and I think that that's what we have you
can at the same time have examples of
anti feh or whoever treating law
enforcement poorly and attacking them
and they should be held to account but
mostly we have a population that by and
large respects police and treats them
well this is not shocking and there was
a very similar backfire when Fox News
anchors during the Bernie Sanders Fox
News Town Hall they asked the room who
would really give up their for-profit
employer linked health insurance for a
government program no one would do that
right and basically the entire rooms
hands went up and they cheered remember
this I want to ask the audience a
question if you could raise your hand
here a show of hands of how many people
get their insurance from work private
insurance right now how many get it from
private insurance okay now of those how
many are willing to transition to what
the senator says a government-run system
whoa whoa we can't be having that
another one of these hilarious backfires
that just it allows the tiniest bit of
reality into the prevailing FoxNews
narrative and it can convince a few
people now if you really want to see a
tax on first responders to go back to
what Fox News is talking about if you
want to see a tax on the military on
public servants and government employees
look at the Oval Office look no further
than Donald Trump I cannot think of any
president that has gone after the FBI
prisoners of war gold star families
intelligence Anna
diplomats public servants more than
Donald Trump has it's another example of
projection plain and simple and isn't it
delightful to see it backfire in the
faces of fox news anchors that we have
come to a see try this stuff again and
again and again over the years I think
it's a great to see and it does
hopefully help to pierce at least a few
people's echo chambers and filter
bubbles make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show while you are there follow
me on instagram at david pakman updates
from my garden coming up later today
possibly breaking news contained there
for sure today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinka is a great service that I use all
the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out soccer
na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do have
after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS Jobs and there is a great new book of
BS Jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/p a que mas